can i squish your cheeks
that's silly
your daily dose of sweetness is
sponsored by kim kardashian and her
three-year-old daughter chicago who just
asked her mom a very important
don't have any fingers here
how come we don't have any fingers there
the kkw beauty founder shared the q-clip
to instagram thursday featuring a
snuggled up moment with her little girl
who just wants to know why we don't have
a sixth finger totally valid question
for the record i've pondered the same
before too
i'm gonna do how many fingers here
how come we don't have any fingers there
why do you think
oh no
you don't know
what what if we need to grab things
i don't know
why do you think
i
i guess we need to squish things we need
to squish things like what what do we
need to squish like a squishy
for slime
honestly that's a great point and if her
teeny little voice and her inquisitive
little mind didn't get you in your feels
just you wait can i squish your cheeks
that's silly
kim has been spending lots of time with
her four children whom she shares with
her ex kanye west who's excited from paw
patrol
last week she celebrated her new
animated film paw patrol the movie with
a special private screening at a theater
for her kiddos shy and eight-year-old
north five-year-old saint and
two-year-old song
i am at the premiere of paw patrol the
first ever paw patrol movie
look what is set up and the reality star
gave a little speech before the movie
kicked off explaining why the project
was particularly meaningful to her
okay guys i want to welcome everyone
here to the paw patrol movie i'm so
excited that i get to show all my kids
and all the cousins and all my friends
and everyone
my first movie
[Applause]
oh i know i have but this is different
this is like an animated movie this is
so cool i did this for you guys
because i know that how much you've
always loved paw patrol and i'm so
excited
all right so let's start the movie guys
a source recently told et that the kids
are kim's top priority since filing for
divorce from kanye west after six years
of marriage in february having kids is
just there's no way to describe it but
it's a lot quote kim is really going out
of her way to make sure the kids are
preoccupied at all times ensuring that
they are busy and keeping them living in
the moment
so whether it's an answer to an anatomy
question
i
don't have any fingers here or hanging
out at the movies who's excited for paw
patrol
kim is all about that quality family
time
[Music]
you